President Vladimir Putin has had some
chilling words for Poland he says that
Moscow will treat any aggression against
Belarus with all means at its disposal
now this comes after reports suggesting
Poland had deployed troops to its border
with Belarus on Thursday mercenaries
from Russia's Wagner group began
training belarussian soldiers near the
Polish border you'll recall that Wagner
forces relocated to Belarus after last
month's short-lived Mutiny against
Russia's military leadership during his
televised address President Putin also
had this message for the Polish
government
thanks to Soviet Union to Stalin Poland
got significant amount of lands in the
west lands that used to belong to
Germany it is so western territories of
Poland at the present given by Stalin to
polls our friends and warsa had
forgotten about it we will remind them
well let's bring in Julia chapovalova
she's in Moscow Yulia there is a meeting
of the United Nations security Council
today and I see Putin has been speaking
about Poland what did he say
well first Legend Putin's lashed out at
the Polish leadership saying they're
seeking to form a coalition under the
NATO umbrella to intervene in the
conflict in Ukraine and enacts a large
piece of the Ukrainian territory uh also
Poland wants to seize part of The Bella
Russian territory and if it goes ahead
and unleashes a war against Belarus it
will be the war against Russia as both
countries are part of the union state so
Russia is ready to retaliate also Putin
has said that the West is disappointed
with the ongoing Ukrainian
counter-offensive as it has no results
saying that the Ukrainian Armed Forces
suffered huge losses tens of thousands
of soldiers and he also criticized the
Western weapons delivered to the country
to Ukraine according to him the Western
Equipment I was even inferior to the old
soviet-made equipment
Yulia I believe the Russian Deputy
foreign minister has also made some
remarks they're about the grand deal
what's been the latest
that's right we've just heard from a
deputy foreign minister is Sergeant and
he commented on the statement by the
Russian defense Ministry that ships in
the blank sea would be considered
carriers of military cargo by Russia he
said that the vessels would be inspected
in order to find out what they were
carrying and uh well basically the
issues of future Transit of ships in the
Black Sea will be discussed during
possible new contacts between Vladimir
Putin and president the Turkish
president a Turkish president erdogan
while the Kremlin also commented on
kiev's statements regarding Russian
ships
um in the Black Sea Kiev also considers
Russian ships near its ports legitimate
military Target so Dimitri peskov called
kiev's statement dangerous and said that
Russia would develop recommendations and
measures to minimize the risks and
danger to its ships
are there for us in the Russia capital
thank you Yulia well let's bring in Nina
kusheva she is a professor of
international Affairs at the new school
she's also the great granddaughter a
former Soviet leader Nikita Khrushchev
she joins us now also from Moscow Nina
let's start with what's happening on the
Poland Belarus border now given the
sensitivities around the Wagner Mutiny
in Moscow what do you make of the
strident rhetoric that we're now hearing
from Putin
well I mean it's
Putin speaking uh it is interesting
because he's speaking to his Security
Council and not often the Security
Council is actually having that in
public so so that is an important moment
Putin decided to open it up to everybody
to hear that very systemic as they say
in Russia's systemic that it's not just
about tactical measures what needs to be
done on the ground and you know what the
goals of special meal preparation in
Ukraine that's how they call the war
here but he goes into this historical
diatribes to convince uh the public too
that you know Poland actually has to be
uh grateful to the Soviet Union to
Russia and instead they are becoming
more and more enemy to Russia and also
this is a message to the ukrainians
please remember that for many many years
in fact many many centuries uh Ukraine
and Poland were not great friends and so
now you're really being duped so this is
really multi-layered uh propaganda
message on the Kremlin part you know it
does seem though that we are hearing
this emerging narrative from the Kremlin
about Poland threatening territorial
sovereignty is key of listening
um I don't know I mean I assume they do
they must be uh but I don't know if it's
emerging because we actually heard that
before that uh that the actual goal in
Poland or for Poland to be so helpful to
ukrainians is indeed that that they want
to bite out this Parts they used to be
polish parts and and whatnot so that
that message actually uh comes in and
out of the rhetoric but now of course
with Belarus and Wagner group being
there and Poland bringing troops uh to
the border with Belarus and also Poland
saying that it would like to carry uh
potentially carry NATO
um uh uh NATO nuclear uh nuclear Arsenal
to some degree so that's why I think
Poland has become uh quite a bit of
piece of rhetoric uh in the Kremlin so
the rhetorical parts are certainly
spreading its geography well Poland has
been I believe amongst the large just
suppliers of military aid to Ukraine and
I recall president zielinski went to
Warsaw in April the presidents gave
those joint speeches at the Royal Castle
as you suggested I know they've had a
difficult relationship in the past the
two countries there are obviously
tensions now about grain Imports but
right now they do look like very close
Military Allies how is all of that
perceived in Moscow
well they are very close Military Allies
and that's why the Putin propaganda
message is pushing that is that uh
reminding the ukrainians that uh you
know this is all now uh when Poland it's
not because Poland wants to uh to stand
with Ukraine but it is all because of
all this historical tensions and going
on a war going on for uh for hundreds of
years that's just in fact to remind you
the ukrainians that this is all not a
benevolent behavior on Poland spot
that's why I think that propaganda
rhetoric is increasing because Ukraine
and Poland are getting closer and it is
in the Kremlin interest to portray that
closest as uh uh some very mercenary uh
interests of Poland uh in Ukraine Nina
just briefly I do want to ask you
because Russia's pulled out of the grain
deal and I see that Poland is now saying
that it will unilaterally block trade
with Ukraine if the European commission
fails to extend into the restrictions on
grain Imports that it's put in place now
that sounds like it's been pretty
damaging to warsaw's relationship with
Kevo or potentially could be do you
think that this is moscow's decision to
also try to drive a further wedge in
here
I don't think so I think that when Putin
says that you know that that the um that
the deal was not uh was not convenient
for for the Russian side because none of
his demands were met I think he he
really means it uh but I think this is
the just this is the complexities of
global relationship this is a complex
complexities of uh relationship of
neighboring countries I'm in Poland I
don't doubt that Poland is uh is firmly
standing with Ukraine but also Poland
has its own uh agricultural interests
and so far what we've seen is that
Ukraine and Poland have been uh able to
handle this kind of complex agricultural
relationship quite well and so I I don't
doubt that they will continue to do so
but for Putin it isn't important once
again it is an important way of of
putting in a wedge in between the two
countries brain deal I think it's uh I
mean it's a marginal much larger uh
problem uh Putin than just relationship
on the
a relationship between Poland and
Ukraine sure and Nina a professor of
international Affairs at the new school
thank you so much for joining us on Al
Jazeera Nina and for sharing your
expertise